what's up everybody welcome to flagrant
two it's your boy schulze i'm here with
akash singh alex media mark gagnot even
got the truffle in here and we have
a very special guest my dear friend
um one of the guys i
i you started comedy a little bit after
me yeah but we came up around the same
time yeah uh great guy very happy for
your success recent success fresh off
his hbo special this is everything we
have ricky velez in the building show
the people
here's everything oh here's everything
sorry here's everything uh i like the
campaign that's really cool in the city
when i'm in an uber uh looking over and
seeing uh the what are they called i
don't know when they put the yeah i
think my dad's out there riding on them
though people be riding the route of
[ __ ]
i saw i saw one that was uh like they
took away the private area yeah they
keep doing that they keep doing that and
it's funny because they're not touching
anybody but i'm it's calling attention
that's what i wanted from it so it was
what it was it's great it's good i loved
it
naked with the microphone hanging out
hanging down yeah it should be it was
fun again
mark
took that photo who the like the famous
photographer mark zeliger who's that i
don't know he like shot obama's last day
in office he shot uh he he shot he
shoots bruce springsteen he's like he's
the man you had heavy hitters working on
this special yeah you said to me that
the guy who did the lighting for
hamilton did your lighting yeah
uh
no stage oh the stage
okay okay okay i don't know yeah judd
works with the sickest people man
produced by judd
yeah okay good do not hold that against
the special dispatchers
i mean this sincerely ricky is one of
the funniest [ __ ] on the planet
and mad love i think that you all i knew
andrew when he had that long hair yeah
looking like him
so we had wild times i remember when i
first met ricky ricky was was running
the
prom shows
remember this yeah it was a broadway
comedy club and so the prom shows
basically what happened were well you
could break it down how does it how does
the prom show work bro you just do shows
at two o'clock in the morning for
children who were drunk yeah they were
dope yeah yeah it was like the only
stage time i was really getting at they
were dope for you because you were their
age yes
murdering these [ __ ] shows and all
those like why are we talking to
teenagers like the [ __ ] we doing here
but that's what it was you had that long
hair they were creeped out yeah that's
true
as hell bro it's like you're telling sex
jokes that like work when you're talking
to like 20 year olds and 30 year olds
but you're talking to like 18 year old
boys yeah
yeah they got it they definitely got it
yeah it was the girls i was weirded out
tell them
but like so you would run the prom shows
yeah for that guy what was his name uh
eric i want to say his last name okay
fine we won't do that i saw him at dumbo
house the other day bro yeah i was like
this is not good was he a little creepy
yeah big time i always heard that about
him yeah the rumor was that he you know
chris d was managed by him too no yeah
go to ask chris d about it don't put
that on me diddy yeah so then what
happened did dude i don't know nobody
else's eric rivera
[Laughter]
i don't know he's the only new yorker
that stays snitching on everybody it's
crazy bro
you and rapping port bro
all these [ __ ] forgot where
they're from they got a podcast bro
bro this guy's out here you know he's
taking advantage of you young latinos
he's taking advantage of cute young
latino comics i had to go out there and
do something about it i only did those
prom shows to look after you
he would go into the green room with you
and i would go with you to make sure
that you i love you so
it much him when he was trying to know
what's so know who you have to protect
me from i'll be honest how are you
talking about this guy i stay trolling
his instagram yeah like the other day he
wrote that nice thing about your parents
working in the radio city thing
and underneath it i wrote uh this is
triggering to people that don't have
parents
and bro your fans be so funny
let them have this moment
and i just leave that [ __ ]
there and like i'd be calling him we're
texting
and his fans are like take that energy
elsewhere
come on you really think i'm over here
crying
we had good moments bro there's a
hilarious video y'all in amsterdam
oh andrew got high
it is so [ __ ] funny the highest i've
ever been was with ricky obviously
wait what happened so i don't even smoke
weed i remember the name of the play
you're mentally no no no no the wolf cop
was what i started
saying oh my god
yeah yeah
so
we're in amsterdam for what like three
hours three hours why are you in
amsterdam okay we're doing it we got put
on a tour through caroline okay yeah so
let's set this whole thing up so
basically let me get the lighter
basically what happens is this right got
it we we basically do this new york
comedy tour in europe so we get to
perform in do you remember getting into
the fight with all the kids from england
to like day two
and they were like there was no women on
your tour and you're like we didn't book
it oh yeah
and it's actually a very famous comedian
now that like is
who the only english guy everybody knows
that's young
oh really yeah it was him
you really not gonna say his name i
don't know it oh all right well how does
he the only one
because he's popping right now he's
popping right now really yep bro ricky
doesn't snitch i like that [ __ ] anyway
i didn't [ __ ] that guy dude he was such
a [ __ ] loser right for women
he was standing up for women wasn't no
he was attacking us because our strong
her show was stronger that's what was
really happening we were having very we
were definitely the crazy toy like a
partner you don't know ricky he's a
[ __ ]
murderer murderer on stage
okay go on we get to europe for three
hours and like i'm somebody that's like
i don't like to miss it but andrew likes
to like just go and do [ __ ] without even
talking to anybody like he's just like
we're leaving the airport yeah
okay fine the captain's driving the show
in amsterdam by the way no we're not we
just stopped in amsterdam and then we're
going to other city we're doing five
different cities right yeah which ones
were they do you remember i know we went
to iceland was wild
sick
oh man that we were in uh norway when
soldier boy came out with that song
i bombed
that was where your boy was from in
[ __ ] sweden bro
it was stockholm i ate my dick
my homies always getting [ __ ] up
i
and he had his homie with us and
i got off stage and he's like yo you
don't talk about drugs here yeah yeah
like i opened up being like yo i'm i'm
hot and they're like no no no no like
they don't [ __ ] with that it was like
andrew on a prom show
i just bombed i didn't see your set but
i just i walked past you we ate bear
that night
you think we're playing we ate bear that
night that's a real [ __ ] story dude
they served us bear of course it wasn't
gonna be a good show i had a belly full
of bear dude
when you walk behind me dude
like you know the scene in the movie
where like you're a ghost and the person
doesn't see you but you see them
and you're like
that's what i felt like the ghost this
guy that we've been living together for
like the last week and he just walks
right by me and i go ricky is everything
okay he goes [ __ ] sweden
[Laughter]
amsterdam to go on to another plane and
andrew's like let's go let's go we find
a cab driver right and the guy's just
down to kick it with us for the all
three hours we just say take us to the
closest coffee shop to the weed spot
which is a mistake because every
airport's in a bad neighborhood yeah
i've been to amsterdam i've seen like
two black people the whole time i've
ever been there yeah we went to a place
that was only about strictly
just moroccans they didn't they weren't
speaking any language we recognized it
was it was impressive dude then they're
telling me to take hash and put it
behind my belt to bring it for the rest
of the tour and i'm like dude you guys
are like
i'm not smuggling for you yeah so we're
like give us your strongest [ __ ] no no
no i said weakest
you said
and you don't smoke weed but andrew
rolls the illest joints in the world
that's really crazy i do really good job
so they give us white lotus
remember this
white lotus before that was hot that was
that was that was the one
and you smoked it you were fine more
than fine i smoked it and i thought i
was gonna be able to bring you back to
the airport you did think that was gonna
happen oh no you remember what happened
when we got back to the airport no no no
so this dude's wiling bro
a leather jacket do you remember
first of all i see
i see a wolf poster right and then all
of a sudden i hear a cop siren right oh
your high brain so my hybrid connects to
and i go i go ricky
the wolf cops are coming
by the way we've left our suitcases in
this car with a man that we've never met
before
i'm on that white lotus bro i'm on the
white lotus so this video i saw was you
laughing hysterically talking about wolf
cup bro
and then
the guy pulls up somewhere we just stop
it like and he turn andrew turns to his
right and there's a leather coat sitting
on top of like a mailbox a mailbox but
like place there like the mailbox has
put over it
and i just look at it and you know the
wolf cops are chasing us and like yeah
just like i go there's a leather jacket
for no reason
do you still have
then we get back to the airport and i'm
worried about him so i'm not even paying
attention to myself like i can control
myself but i don't know how andrew's
gonna get that oh no this is great this
is great this is great i'm the high one
right i'm the one that's gonna [ __ ] [ __ ]
up at the airport i'm super high okay go
so i'm like paying attention to andrew
and not myself
and we start going through security
and i just forgot to take everything out
of my pockets
so i'm looking at andrew he walks
through smooth then me
they don't just do it like pat you down
on the floor bro they put you basically
like in the air so everybody can watch
you be like like now i'm standing on
like two milk crates
you gotta understand like this back when
ricky used to dress like chris angel
like everything on him
everything on him was metal he had like
three to be honest you had like three
necklaces you had like bracelets and all
this kind of [ __ ] and you're in the
machine it wasn't like a beeping thing
it was like the machine where you throw
the triangle up right so he's in the
machine and they're looking at him crazy
when he walks in the machine because
he's got so much
that just just starts going and
literally the tsa is like yo what the
[ __ ] is wrong
they almost
put me up on this pedestal thing and
[ __ ] started searching me and he's
now on the other side clear laughing
like on the floor laughing at me
dying bro unbelievable trip oh so good
so funny it was so good we lived in
norway for like eight days
our tour manager left us
why yeah what happened with that our
tour manager dipped on us because they
lied to us about the money
oh [ __ ]
i can see
what happened they lied to us about the
money they told us we were supposed to
be getting like like money throughout to
like pay for every and they just stopped
and the tour manager took off with uh on
us and left with that [ __ ] guy that
won't get vaccinated what's his name
brewer oh jim brewer was on the tour
with us he was great though he was fun
yeah nah he was fun
i'm missing no snitch i'm missing no
talking [ __ ]
i can talk [ __ ] i'm not snitching you
snitch i snitch
yeah but ricky also industry savvy so he
knows he can [ __ ] on brewery
[Music]
you